[Music]
I'm Christopher Hine and this week we're
talking about
addo key so hadou key is our
disentanglement methods how do we stop
someone from holding us it's important
to understand that in Hadopi we're not
trying to grapple with anyone I don't
want to grapple with someone I just want
them to not be able to grapple with me
so I'm just trying to clear them off of
me
in Aikido the idea is the other person
is always bigger stronger faster
whatever than us so they have a lot more
ability than we do and that could also
come from skill maybe they're just more
skilled grapplers than we are so instead
of investing a whole lot of time and
getting better at grappling in Aikido we
have the Hadouken
which gets us out of that range ideally
now if that didn't work out for you you
do need to understand jujitsu so just
use a valuable skill but if we could
solve the problem before it ever got to
jujitsu in Aikido that's ideally what we
would like to have going for us so the
Hadopi are clearing methods last week we
worked on cop the door we talked about
the basic fundamentals of vetters
yesterday we talked about cop the dory
and the basic fundamentals of that this
week we're going to talk about real cop
the dory and who shiro a real cop that
already so if they have both shoulders
and a lot of the same techniques will
work as from cop the dory but we have a
couple of the things we need to account
for so I'm gonna call Josh over here
we're gonna go to work for you guys Josh
all right so we talked to yesterday
about Commodore II today we're gonna
talk about real cop the dory and a shear
real cut the dory
understand for the most part a lot of
the things we do in pop the door will
kind of work out for us in a real cop
the dory but we shouldn't have caught
that array and caught the during have
some other kind of things we can exploit
mainly ways that we can bind those two
arms together so it's the basic Gigi
principle where we're binding arms
together
so if Josh were to grab me real
glory a lot of times I could still get a
triangle just like normal so
here and you get a triangle the emphasis
has to be that I have to put a little
more pressure in this with my arm coming
up so if I just did a regular triangle
here this little clear real easy I just
let me go to the other side so they can
see so I come out here this one will
clear really easy but this one I kind of
have to do a little extra work to pop it
off but when I'm working that if I come
up and I kind of pop that up I'll get a
boat so I can use a triangle just 74
would you worry will work and if you
want to work really really nicely so
maybe if I roll under this here like
this I'll start putting his arms
together there to bind them and pop free
so as I'm coming around get those arms
working together and that's basically
the jutsu principle now when you're
going underneath you have to be careful
that that foot can be coming up now
understand we're moving at this point so
I'm not gonna like to stand here like
Superman and he's gonna grab in then I'm
gonna do some sweet awesome Aikido
Septim that's never gonna happen I'm
running and he managed to get this so
his feet are probably moving fast but
nonetheless I don't want to stick my
face down here because he can he can
bring that hand up so my arms trail out
here in front of me like this
so if the knee does come up at least it
hopefully gets deflected a little bit as
I'm coming through so won't my head to
be in through my hands and then I'm
diving through them binding those arms
together now we're looking at how those
arms are getting bound together here
like this so if you watch Josh's arms
right here actually should have moved to
the other direction sir I'm trying to
get those arms together like this and
I'm working them one against the other
so this one is being pushed against this
one and they're both working for me to
get that free now of course when I'm
popping free I prefer not to be in this
position I'd be trying to move here to
get a heat though of me or an eating me
position from this so that's my goal
so whenever that's happening I'm trying
to find one arm against the other and
use them against each other so that's
how we would work our Buchi warrant now
our silk Awards are generally not gonna
work for us now the reason for this is
because this grips really good you can
always kind of use it to track around so
as I'm pushing one off you can always
kind of track me track me track me I
might get away with so don't worry if I
did it really fast and I was stronger
than him but if I'm not I probably never
gonna get away with that so I'm going to
be stuck to more of using triangle
options and Ujima luring options right
when we do that together called
she and that's to go around the arms
themselves now that we're in wash you
will also come up when we renew shear
real cockpit or so from this position
here my root idea is gonna be to come to
a 45 put pressure on this inside arm and
pull the other one free so I'm going to
go here and that's what I'm looking for
is to get that completely free so I'm
applying poi this way and applying
pressure to this hand this way as I come
up and I'm looking to get that kind of
escape that's my general idea now when I
do that notice I go to the 45 position
basic economy and will end up in economy
that way so as I come out Bank here
would be right here in this position
them setting up the hi hon me and I'd go
from Heathrow me to eating me here if I
had my way now if that doesn't work for
it so if I turn out here then all I need
to do is continues to follow up so I go
here I'm gonna put those arms together
here and moving there I'm combining his
arms together with that Jiu Qi principle
again and working for that loot am
owashi Stubbs coming around his arms to
twist him up same thing is happening
from there now along the lines lots of
other techniques might arise because of
what he's doing he's really flexible or
really rigid all kinds of different
stuff can happen but those are the root
techniques I'm using to clear myself and
improve my position so when he's got me
here
I can use a lot of the general things I
would use for contouring but I really
working trying if those arms bound up
together and that's gonna be what will
probably most decisively get me free the
same is true from the rear position I'm
gonna try to just quickly pop off but if
he sticks with me I'm gonna go through
that now in this rear position if I
start to move this way he could push me
with this hand and pull with the other
one so notice what's happening is I'm
trying to go this way and as I'm trying
to go he's correcting that by going like
this then I can slide to the inside but
again I'm just pressing those arms
together that's what I'm trying to do is
get those arms together to get him to
let go of me if I can let me get him to
let go of just one side that's a big
improvement in my situation if I you're
letting games like go both that would be
really really good right so these are
the basic ideas I'm going to be using
when we when we're looking for Hadopi
from either Rio
or Shiro ryokan Tory next to tomorrow I
keep saying next week but tomorrow we're
going to look at top it or in capita
Tory and the basic fundamentals for
clearing tat Dory's I'm Christopher Hine
thanks for watching
[Music]